et le maire gérard charlet et sans
maréchal jean marie chanson georges
picard bon pilule et le chef de la bande
des blousons noirs des batignolles et
patrice de cormeilles est un élève du
lycée carnot qui a ouvert sa cave
personnelle non pour y boire mais pour
s'y distraire au blouson des batignolles
en même temps qu'à ses camarades de
lycée dans cette cave donc de jeunesse
opposés se retrouve ce petit fait attire
l'attention
il signifie en tout et pour tout qu'une
bande de blousons noirs a accepté de
sortir de son isolement
à cause de cette attitude nouvelle nous
sommes allés voir cette bande de garçons
dont un quart environ se trouve en
liberté surveillée leur lieu de
rassemblement et ce café la cigale les
réponses aux questions que je leur ai
posé sont souvent brutales choquant est
presque toujours exprimé dans un langage
violent
on ne combat pas un mal en l'ignorant
nous avons essayé de savoir si non le
comprendre à quelle mentalité correspond
le comportement habituel du blouson noir
et dans quelle mesure cette mentalité
peu tous n'ont évolué
reportage que vous allez entendre et
voir n'apporteront aucune conclusion
laissant à chacun le soin de juger
[Musique]
toi le chef d'abyei oui ou non si l'on
veut pourquoi six ans maintenant parce
qu'il y avait un gars j'aime chez nous
il n'ya pas à dire maintenant depuis
combien de temps tu aideras pas en notre
bande ku qu'elle remonte à trois ans
quatre ans mais avant il avait levé
avant la charly jacquot du toit lettres
combien une vingtaine pas plus non pas
parce que vous comptez les lois qui sont
là tous les soirs
quel âge as tu sais pas le plus vieux
noms seront maintenus musique19 en cage
est bien mieux là elle va sur 20 est le
plus jeune je ne savoir 15 ans il faut
maintenant que le banc alors un an et
demi quel métier tu as fait j'étais
télégraphiste florrick quincaillier
coursiers du match et premier du travail
régulièrement
oui et c'est combien de temps de plus
deux ans chez le même patron c'est le
même patron je travaille aujourd'hui on
n'est pas travailler quoi on se dira ça
j'étais malade et puis ce matin salle
est pas encore là lui c'était ma toute
la matinée pour faire pour le moment que
des tags racistes aussi à prendre en ce
propos pourquoi du parti
1 enfin la mode c'est à dire un pour le
télégramme puis il ne portait le soir
seulement par ce service
il est comme ça allait plus vite le
service et commettant qui fait partie de
la bande à faire un nom je suis avant
tout à chez ma mère puis tu es partie
nos lendemains d'hier est comme ça obama
l'avait un julian a foutu la lourde
question faisait à ce moment là
l'assemblage été tirés lors de plans et
comment ça s'est passé
quand on a viré au bas ça faisait déjà
de trois jours je ne donnais pas bouffer
alors j'avais demandé une avance sur ma
paye
puis jusqu'au jour j'ai mon avance je
suis rentré quand j'étais à bien dit fou
mal quand j'ai repris la pente me
séparer qu'est ce tu as fait bon ben
j'ai été ce que j'ai fait j'ai bouffé
ans succède au cinéma et après cinéma
mais je me suis battu dans paris quoi au
mois de janvier alors j'ai un peu froid
puis ça fait ça pendant cinq six jours
puis ensuite ça lundi quoi là on m'a
entouré de quoi coucher j'ai couché là
chez les personnes chez voiture à la
moyenne j'ai bouché pendant deux mois et
après ils pouvaient pas me garder alors
on a trouvé deux autres personnes pour
me prendre ta médaille tribunal de
personnes qui m'ont pris quoi regarder
pendant deux ou trois mois mais alors là
ça n'allait pas il savait il y avait des
fils et des filles à metz les dimanches
et robert alors c'était pas mon genre
j'avais été chez les curés mais j'allais
but alors là c
je vais partir de chez eux et alors
c'est là que j'ai rencontré diane gr
j'avais été convoqué au palais de
justice alors je n'avais pas été quoi
alors diana mauvaise foi femmes 10
minutes à feu doux et à des taux réduits
à les candidats attendent une paire de
claques
alors les asiles de malades agence une
plaque à premier forme enfants puis la
veille j'avais d'aller intermission puis
alors je veux palais de justice alors il
ya comment monsieur brièvement essayés
il commença m'attraper oui il dit on ne
peut rien pour coucher et on va tout
mettre au dépôt alors moi des pochettes
qu'est-ce que c'était quoi quand j'ai
dit est ce qu'on mange bien est-ce qu'on
couche bien on dit oui à l'islam js
conservation m'a dit non à sallanches et
plus je pouvais pas senti a rejeté pour
livre car c'est là que diane ali lundi
vous me laissez ce mois de mai a dit me
laisser pendant un mois bien dit ça
marche pas je ramenais alors c'est un
marché parce que je suis la soeur puis
alors depuis ce temps là c'est toujours
équipé ii - quoi d'ailleurs quasiment me
remplacer la merde
williams et vous et oui diam's et moi
quel est votre titre exactement je suis
délégué bénévole à la liberté surveillée
je dépose directement du tribunal pour
enfants le retrouve essentiellement du
travail
oui j'ai peur pour faire je m'efforce de
le retrouver du travail
à quel ordre mondial at elle trouvé du
boulot ouais bah ouais j'ai mis à part
ces noms n'ont pas trouvé mais à la
rangée pour moins de 7
vous ne savez pas qui sont ces garçons
que vous venez d'entendre pilule vous
les présente et ado boys lui est
plombier qui a 20 ans il ya un bébé qu'à
18 ans qu'est ce qui fait qu'elle veut
et dégraisseurs dans un garage
serge qu'on appelle le martyre puisque
chaque fois qu'on se faisait arrêter par
les flics et qui avait une corrida qui a
toujours aidé les flics de cogner la
gueule au point qu'il a été marqué si
mike à chaque fois qu'il prend les coups
sur la gueule et pourquoi son parce que
rempli la première fois je me suis
attardé c'est ses rues de lévis ont
emmené de se promener de par là au parc
on l'avait attaqué des vieilles les
grosses conneries comme ça
alors moi j'essaie de me sauver c'est
normal j'étais pour habituer à soissons
lors de l'achat ne me suis jamais plié
par l'epic alors y en a un qui meurent
attaque par les poings et coups de
savates à coups de fil cinéma
alors comment vous les aimez aussi ils
ont quel genre de la bêtise tu permets
de faire toi quel est le maximum que tu
me permets de faire je suis je pourrai
mieux répondre à cette question pas plus
que vous répondre si madeleine
pourquoi au noir la menthe ouais ouais
d'accord on regarde un peu les gens
criaient je suis hanté au mieux de la
rue
qu'est ce qui les gêne parce que les ja
et a déjà fermé mine mal vous le dire
comme lilian façon durandal adjoint
commissaire la société nous amènent pour
les jo nous mêmes pour les jeunes
en haïti les jeunes c'est vrai il y en a
qui lie japon pour dire qu est ce qui se
fait de 10 verges au dimanche on va à la
patinoire laquelle patinoire vous allez
le lit marin fédéral verrait bien comme
l'ensemble toujours à fédéral way un
jour alors pourquoi s'être au départ
c'est la meilleure ambiance
ce qui nous arrive d'aller au bal
quelque part on se fait rare
[Musique]
chez nous en général et dans ce point
non s'amuse pas ses proches ses amis ce
point c'est parce qu'ils n'ont jamais
essayé en l'art a déjà fait les mails à
la patinoire c'est un reportage pour
plusieurs raisons voyez d'abord il ya
des filles qui est derrière votre les
dimanches en plus de ça c'est un peu la
route on tente de les blousons noirs si
l'on peut dire c'est et tous les copains
à la boîte tous les quartiers en plus ça
fait une journée pro cheikh tall et on
s'amuse bien
[Musique]
personne ne fait politique non personne
ne fait ça veut dire que vous n'avez pas
l'opinion ou bien que romain les doigts
qu'on les opinions et les gardent pour
eux toi tu en as pas m'intéresse pas
personnellement nous aurait pas de
risque car et de dire des conneries je
préfère me taire qu'est ce que vous avez
fait jeudi dernier vous avez été
manifestée à cons pour soutenir la
politique pour soutenir l'économie qui
existent bien si on applique c'est
dégueulasse et un point chez nous qui
prenons les coûts voilà son retour il a
décollé quelques chabada vous servir au
départ contre qui vous seriez ou pas
vraiment à laver ils sont venus
eux-mêmes nous le dira alors il faut
dire que vous avez loin tabasser les
vraies mais quand il le tabac sida ne
demande pas un thermicien chaîne de vélo
manivelle est un peu tôt pour les jo
mais ces snobs la salle et navals dans
la vie là-bas c'est les mecs qui sont
toujours en costard qui sont trop
prétentieux c'est ça que j'aime pas les
études montrent à elle pour les payer
ces petits points sur la plupart c'est
comme ça visionnez mais qui se bat pour
l'arménie vont ils m'ont violée sur les
champs elysées n'importe où pour ans y
va pour la voilà pourquoi parce qu'elle
avait un temps ils sont même pas en
l'armé aubaine pour quelles raisons nous
on s'en va à l'armée attend tapi dans le
fond je trouve qu'il est plutôt content
de partir non a donc je suis pas content
directement de partir si on m'appelle
c'est normal que j ai un mais ces gars
là pourquoi pourquoi compte pourquoi
qu'on les envoie pas comme vous aucun
regret donc pour la médecine de grosses
conneries comme ça et moi non parce que
les que nous allons voir
oui qu'est-ce qui a déjà qu'il est
normal de casser la figure pas ouais et
tente
voici si quelqu'un delà de la bande
je pense sac à main d'une femme par
exemple
tu regardes tu regarde pas ça dépend du
gras qu'est ce que tu veux dire
et à l'époque qui font que ça il semble
que ce soit un gars qui serait ce pas à
son premier coup pas seulement une
connerie qui puisse attirer les ennuis
tout ça et si c'est pas là la première
connerie parce que là et c'est pas la
peine car yen il veut et paraît
aléatoire votre blog puis c'est un
premier pas si c'est la première à ce
qu'on a fait valoir les risques ce qui
court avec yvon garder avec nous il y en
a pour qui on fait exception si c'est
vraiment ça débloque vous dis que ça va
vous changer le monde et que les moeurs
ont changé
oui il ya moins de conneries tu fait
preuve et déjà être avec les deux
travaillé toute la journée ils sont quoi
le square n'ai rien appris par ailleurs
tout commence à changer qu'est ce qui
était permis à un an
ce qui l'est plus maintenant aubin et
supervision des permissions des graisses
en place mais ce qui se passait avant
c'est que les gradés pas et il y avait
des couteaux désactiveront et rues comme
c'est curieux que vaut mieux éviter à
voir maintenant vont éviter d'importer
tous finissent par se fini parce que ça
nous à dire plutôt les dans du coton
puisque vous imposez votre ceinture en
profiter pour la parade gay pas de
vignerons sur et quelques jeunes la
passoire non ce soir
elle soigne pas bon moment avant le soir
toujours acorn house of pop star ses
pratiques et sérieuse violaine que tu as
wihr et oui martin qu'est ce qu'elle
faisait
obama est la raison principale
d'ailleurs c'est que ce qu'il une petite
[ __ ] horner si on peut dire qu'on est
absolument oui on est un peu
heureusement il faut dire qu a été
produit il ya 14 ans et en plus de ça
est une des raisons principales aussi
c'est que la dialyse et commence à s'en
occuper et l ai trouvé des places ou
même ne restez pas que je voulais pas
rester lancé qu'à sa tête et tout ça
alors ça les ponts on va parler du
changement
y avait eu dans la ici depuis six mois
ben oui ça ça a changé en effet à
monsieur depuis que maintenant nous
assistons avec le dis à nos chapelles ça
va beaucoup mieux quoi tu avances à quoi
ça va on peut dire que ça a changé fond
pourquoi pas y ait beaucoup de
changements
les frangines à le changement d'abord
c'est le travail boulot c'est le boulot
c'est le principal changement qui est en
devenir c'est diane qui est en grande
partie responsable de ça parce que c'est
lui qui s'en occupe
les rapports avec les agents de quartier
sont meilleurs qu'ils annoncent qu'ils
se pensaient c'est qu'avant on était
tous les sens pas rentrer du boulot
référence réalisé au square
automatiquement alors se fraye toutes
les deux meilleurs il y avait les
cliques qui procède automatiquement se
retrouver à emballer au poste bas
maintenant ils nous ont trop à la bombe
qui ne demandent pas histoire fait que
tu viens ici ah oui si on est beaucoup
plus tranquille
pourquoi son mieux les free qui leur
disent plus rien n'indique là bas à la
baule confesse rien du tout une mono
papier comme on est de montreuil sitôt
au poste bon mais maintenant puisque
vous êtes de l'extérieur vous devez
avoir une idée ces scènes de ce qui se
passe et si l'on changeait vraiment ici
ah oui je trouve changé oui sont les
besoins encore sont des blousons voulant
maintenant non c'est plus les blues ont
ouvert tard dans du bidule
ouais mon frère là qui y parle conduit à
des blouson blanc et supporter à fait
d'accord avec lui disons qu'on est un
petit chemin entre on est mitigé entre
le noir et blanc ça fait un peu gris
parce que si on est on est pas
complètement blanc s'est vérifié on
continue quand même faire une petite
connerie c'est à dire à faire le bordel
dans le quartier faire du bruit et
tapage nocturne tout ça d'accord on fait
tout ça bon et bien d'entre nous qui
font sur les des petits larcins ton en
temps arrive pas je peux pas appeler
autrement les besoins des plus hauts
blancs ne comprennent pas encore au
point est ce qu'on fait c'est une telle
furie vous êtes sûre quel chemin d'après
vous
disons qu'on grimpe la gaude pareil
monsieur michel vous êtes propriétaire
de la cigale en tant que client qu'est
ce que vous pensez de dépôt dont moi
binger pas autre chose a bien sûr je ne
m'en plains pas qu'est ce qu'ils boivent
wade diamono café crème café admis au
pire on fera les jamais d'alcool mieux
ça va mieux oui parce que ils craignent
un peu c'est à dire c'est comme des gens
vous mettez dans des rangs et ça leur
ait des fonds dit de sortir c'est pas
tout à fait ça se disent pas son nom
mais enfin malgré tout ils savent que
les penta mokless est suspendue au
dessus d'eux il ya une femme
particulièrement qui le retour du
travail et ma foi faut pas qu'ils
quittent leur place pour une bêtise
quelconque dit monsieur richard monsieur
je vous avais demandé qu'est ce que
c'est que les peines damoclès belle épée
de damoclès existe depuis très longtemps
c'est pour ainsi dire quelque chose qui
est suspendue au dessus de ta tête et ma
foi si tu des rushes qui fait une bêtise
elle tombe sur la tête
bon voici encore quatre questions quatre
réponses qui peut être vous aideront à
conclure qu'est ce qui te manque le plus
en ce moment - sans cela à quoi avez
cela la pente beaucoup ça de quoi tu
environnement qu'est ce qui te manque le
plus nos forces ne ment et ment que rien
pas pour le manger tout ce qu'il faut
puisque je suis arrivé à voir tout ce
qu'il fait je suis heureuse elle que je
suis si qui pouvaient brusquement changé
de vie qu'est ce que tu ferais
maintenant ça commence à changer de vie
tu pouvais ne pas être demain celui qui
aujourd'hui ce que est ce que tu
aimerais faire on bat cantonales ikon
retourner à l'école
pour faire plus tard - orateurs comme
moi j'aime y entre comme ça qu'est ce
qui t'a décidé à changer différentes
choses tu peux en dire quelques mois
d'abord il y avait j'avais 17 ans j'ai
déjà au mois au moment où j'aurai une
chambre moi surtout sak lé café le
changement c'est dingue je dois trouver
d'argent
oui c'est diane et puis en plus histoire
de filles ou 6 mai spéciale non mais je
te demande pas le poser ma question est
pas un disque annoncé l'arrivée mais
l'histoire de chambre est il sauvé les
filles c'est tout mais qu'est ce que tu
veux dire une histoire de filles bas et
c'est à dire que nous en général il n'y
a qu'une chose qui ait loupé le sud une
chose principale qui peut faire changer
un gars ou une deuxième chose c'est à
dire y'a qu'la elle soit une fille soit
des coûts générale et qu'on réussisse
pas mais les filles réussissent assez
bien c'est une fille qu'il avait chargé
un boy
[Musique]